Uh, today's case, a
shell co Seawall, uh, is,
uh, a wonderful transition, uh, to,
uh, Colliers, bottom billion. And
A,
I want to start with some frameworks
and I'm, I'm going to do these briefly.
I'll post them this evening shoe could
look back at them. I want to introduce,
these are very standard Mba ish,
a shorthand frameworks for thinking
about cases. And you heard,
I think most of this, but I,
I should rub it in a bit. Uh,
one is called Swat, s, w o, o t.
And this one has really
no analytic content to it.
It's just a,
a way of organizing your
thoughts on a topic,
a strengths, weaknesses,
opportunities, threat,
uh,
in the temporal dimension.
Typically the strengths and weaknesses
are things which are immediately present
in your situation.
And the opportunities and threats are
things you might have happened to you or
might cause, uh, cause, uh, to occur.
And,
um,
a lot of back of the envelope thinking
about business cases is organized in a,
this shorthand.
Uh,
so you might make yourself a grid like
this and let the column headings be Swat.
And then,
uh,
let the row headings be
whatever you choose. Uh,
but one candidate a is the porter forcer,
uh,
which we've seen before.
Uh,
how fierce is the direct competition in
your business from other people doing
more of us exactly what you do and
trying to do it better than you?
Uh, what's the threat that others not
now doing it will enter the business and
increased competition.
Uh,
how likely is it that people will find
substitutes for your whole industry that,
uh, your industry will be
undermined by an adjacent industry?
Mine
is that
I could tell I was able to
determine which letter it was.
Can you hold that up and
tell us what it's about?
Yeah.
Really quickly
hold it up.
So the video guy,
the Congo,
the kinds of sexual crimes of sexual
violence that are common communes to the
billions as well resolve
the mineral conflict, uh,
such as copper and coal,
uh,
which are frequently found in
our own devices such as iPads,
cell phones and cameras. So just trying
to draw attention to the crisis. Terrific.
It's certainly an eye catching
a accessory as you walk in.
Um,
threat of substitution,
then the power of your
suppliers in the shell case.
Think about where you're buying
the basic components of these,
uh, generation and
lighting systems. Uh, if,
if there's only a limited number of
sources or perhaps even just one store,
then they're in a position
to squeeze you on price.
And that's an important strategic
consideration. And buyers,
if buyers have a lot of leverage
or as in the Selco case,
not a lot of money,
then buyers become a central
point of strategic focus.
So you could, if you
wanted, and I often do this,
you could combine swat across
the top with supply, with,
with a porter in the rows so that,
uh,
if you take a potential
entrance threat of entry,
uh, your strength might be that there's
no money to be made in this field.
So not many people are
going to want to do it.
Or it might be that there are huge
switching costs so that once people have
bought your equipment,
it is very difficult for them to
switch to other people's equipment.
Uh, the weakness might be
that you're making money
and that the Financial Times just ran a
large article about how lucrative your
business is, which is likely to
attract the attention of others,
uh, opportunities. Uh, perhaps, uh,
well how is, how is barriers
to entry and opportunity? Uh,
perhaps you can build pricing advantages.
If you increase the scale
of your operation, uh,
your unit costs may get low enough
that whenever a new entrant comes,
you can crush him with low prices.
Um,
uh,
and threat similarly,
somebody else may jump in and get
to a higher scale of production,
much lower unit costs and crush you.
So you can, you could walk
all the way through, uh,
the 20 cells there. Uh, but it, it,
frameworks like this are meant to
be useful. And when they're useful,
they are there,
you use them.
And if there's a particular cell
here that doesn't make any sense,
you just put an x through it and go on.
Uh,
another concept that
we've used briefly and it,
and it gets to be important in cases
like Selco is vertical integration,
which I've drawn horizontally
as almost everyone else does.
And the rough idea here is that on the
left is the supply of raw materials.
Uh, and then, uh, then making of
the product. It's the assembly,
it's distribution and
sale all the way out here,
the sale and is called the forward part
of integration. So forward integration,
uh,
raw materials and intermediate products
is called backward integration.
And so defying all logic backward
plus forward makes vertical,
don't ask me how that came about.
MMM.
Behind that process,
which we think of in
very physical terms is a,
an intellectual and managerial layer,
which starts not with raw materials,
but with a business plan,
a and a product design and the assembly
of a management team and the creation of
channels for distributing the
product. Again, left to right.
And if you think about the sell coke case,
uh,
where's the, where's their main
focus on this Arrow at Selco?
What do they mostly paying attention to?
Back left, you got to shout.
If you don't have a bike,
they, most of their staff is focused on
distribution and sales. But then India,
okay.
This absolutely.
So the forward integration of
Selco is it's most obvious,
uh,
obviously unusual feature.
They're reaching into very difficult
markets to do the sales and very awkward
places to do the service which
has to go with the sales.
And if you look now at another way of
looking at the backward to forward a
story, it's, I,
I've reproduced what was already there,
but then I've added service out here.
It turns out that taking responsibility
for durable goods that you sell,
right? There's not much
longterm responsibility for
toothbrushes or toothpicks.
Uh, but there is a lot of service
responsibility for any form of machinery,
especially when people are
going to organize our lives
around the machinery. Uh,
the classic insight on a
classic example on this is,
uh,
a McCormick,
a farm machinery in the 18 hundreds.
The brilliant thing they did,
which none of their competitors did,
was to manufacture a only during the
winter season and use the same people that
were running the manufacturing plant
to be servicing agents for the farmers
during the growing season.
So that the advantage
of buying their stuff,
I had everything to do with service. Now
think about the laptop in front of you.
Take Yours. Uh, is service an issue?
Well, does it just run, run
forever and keep you happy?
Okay. And what do you do? Okay.
Or you call him up and talk to talk to it.
So called genius.
What a thought,
right?
The genius bar and Max
Competitive Advantage.
It's partly the elegance of the,
of the equipment,
but a lot of it is that they're servicing
is way better than anybody else's
who's got a kind of computer
that services hard to find for.
You're all perfectly happy with the
support you get for your computers.
Well that's wonderful. It's,
it's improbable but wonderful.
Um,
okay,
so you get a,
with Selco,
a huge emphasis on the
service end of the business.
Okay. Now let's turn to the case
itself. There's an a part and a B part.
The B part is really kind of a more like
a teaching note than an actual case.
And the focus is on a rural,
the a certain rural part of India and on,
uh,
sales to people who are either in
business on a very small scale,
entrepreneurs of some kind or householders
in an area that is off the electric
grid.
And it's an interesting fact about
India that the electric grid is highly
problematic and incomplete. And uh, first,
uh,
mass development of wind turbines was
actually begun in India by a textiles
manufacturer who,
uh,
got tired of all the downtime
in his reliance on grid
electric power and started
developing turbines for his own use.
And then had the,
had the insight that turbines where a
profitable business than textiles for him
and switched all together.
It's now headquartered in
Denmark and it's a huge company.
MMM.
So the alternatives to
what these guys are doing,
the ones mentioned in the
case are the grid Pico, hydro.
And it's very hard for me to envision
how you do distributed generation with
water. I got, well anybody
got a thought about this?
You live next to a running stream and
you build a little water wheel and it's
got to be something a little
glitzy or than that, uh,
and wind turbine on a micro scale
now,
um,
what are the inherent disadvantages of
the distributed generation strategy that
Selco is engaged in?
If you were looking at it from a
business point of view, what would be
factors that would,
would strike you as a
scary?
Uh,
yes.
Every time they entered a new market
they had to convince the finance
institution to finance their products to
the market that they were catering to.
So it was almost a barrier of entry for
them because the kind of people they
wanted to sell the products
to did not have the services.
And it was also a new concept that they
were introducing because financing was
never done with respect to energy before.
Okay.
So one,
one problem that is inherit in the market
segment they choose to serve is that
you've got a twin,
a door to door finance at the
micro level with door to door sale.
Uh, of the, of the equipment,
the generating equipment
and the lighting equipment.
So that's one difficulty.
Are there any others?
Maybe I'll just make carry that around.
Any others?
Yup.
Um, some days there's no
sun and then obviously, yes,
solar system isn't going to work.
There are,
and there are some seasons in which that
happens repeatedly though in the part
of India they're doing, it's a pretty
sunny place. Uh, but okay. So that's,
that's uh,
that's a genuine drawback.
Other other thoughts?
Oh,
there you are.
Essentially they're competing
with the government.
If the government chose to
expand the grid in the region,
they're doing business
that would put there,
that would put their business
plan and they decided decision.
Okay.
So, uh, there's a lot said there all,
all in one elegant sentence.
Uh,
and the, uh, the biggest piece of it,
as I heard it was the threat that the
grid might expand into a given area.
And why would people,
once the grid came,
switched from Shell Cosa
equipment to grid equipment,
we took your mic
probably cost,
it's more efficient to
generate electricity, um, in a,
in a power plant. Then
in your own house. Okay.
And in n is there a general concept here?
Economies of scale,
economies of scale, right?
The whole point of centralized generation,
uh,
is huge economies of
scale, right? So that,
uh, if you, if, if,
if the grid is run reasonably efficiently,
efficiently,
it will time after time
Trump distributed generation.
And so why would we do this business?
What's the point?
Is this something that
uh,
a brilliant young reptile from the Harvard
business school is going to jump into
to make his fortune?
Sasha,
what do you think? No, no. And why not?
I think there are too many risks,
too many risks. And how
big an upside is, sir.
Um, I, I'm not sure how you
would clarify the upside,
but I'm not convinced that it's
huge enough to take advantage.
Okay. Uh, does anybody remember
the financing story for this
work comes what,
what subsidies are required?
Okay,
let's watch a little bit of filming yet
further along with the actual story.
We got the sound. This found cord
up here, guys. I hear it yesterday.
Okay.
I had a chance to go to
Dominican Republic way back in 91
and there I saw actually some villagers
using solar power and paying for it.
That triggered a lot of changes
in my own thought process.
When I came up in the back,
hi was one of the first to realize that
there was potential for selling solar
home systems to individual users.
At the time the only lighting systems
in rural India where community
installations funded by the government.
What we did basically what start
off the operations and and see uh,
solid. Okay, let's,
let's tackle the barriers as they come
rather than studying it and then seeing
what the solutions were. So we
were a three member team, Harish,
no one Mr Pie and I,
the three of us together were the ones
who are the so called management of the
company at that point in time.
And between the three of us,
we delighted the jobs that were dead in
the organization with the taking care of
most of the day to day running of
the organization. Those days, Mr,
by taking care of the operational side of
it and me taking care of the marketing,
we started basically with $30 in the
pocket for three years and we would buy a
for lighting system from a,
from a manufacturer and then sell it
and whatever money we would get in by
another
Hareesh slowly realized that the one
size fits all for light system was not
always the most appropriate or
affordable solution for the rural poor
[inaudible] actually dumping
technology down people's throat.
Even not giving them a choice.
Say that we have for light,
so you need to take four lights
and four lights for what?
See the corridor light was different too
about from light a bathroom light was
very different to our kitchen light.
Why do you need 11 more
light in the bathroom?
You need light for the sake of
having light in the bathroom.
So you can come up with a very small
light of one water or two words.
So we need to give them a
choice of people would say,
are you in the kitchen and in
the dining room at the same time.
So you'd give you four
points with two lights.
So when you're done with the cooking you
shift the light to the dining room and
it effectively acts like
a full light system.
Typical example when uh, when a farmer
came to us and said, we want it,
I want a three light system.
And when we designed a three light
system for the farmer, the farmer Rhino,
it said it's too expensive,
but the technician went to his house when
on top of the house broke a part of it
and put one light.
He wanted light in three rooms.
He did not need three lights and
certainly solo became affordable
because of the different
segmentation of people,
especially the poor. There's no
standardized income generating activities.
Our neighbor might be a midwife. This
side neighbor might be a street render,
the other side neighbor would be a
potato vendor and everybody needs the
different sorts of energy services.
Especially the difference here being
that it's between a need and a warrant.
You definitely can standardize.
I want you cannot standardize a need
because once you look at basic needs and
everybody's needs are very, very
different. I need to ask off lighting.
Somebody needs for us of lighting,
somebody needs one off lighting from
milking the cow as Selco focus on creating
individual solutions.
Business took off. However,
it was not always a smooth ride. Since
your success came pressure to expand,
we got ed wise from well known management
gurus that the way you guys are doing
it is not correct and you need
to not own your own centers.
Why you need to create
a lot of other dealers.
We went to that and created half the
company to create those dealer models.
What happened with that was completely
the mission went for a toss in a sense
that dealer started looking at upper
middle class and high middle class,
so the poor,
well any left behind and because of that
we nearly got killed because the market
was not so maturely developed for the,
even for the middle class
and upper middle class,
the margin levels for what the
dealer's expected were not as high,
so they started tapering down in the
business and we had lots of inventory that
we had bought because of these dealers.
We nearly nearly collapsed.
The mission was going for a toss.
The company was going for a toss.
The what we had actually started
with was going into fourth toss.
We feel that the middle class and
upper middle class, anybody else,
we'll reach them. They have a choice,
they have a choice to go after things,
but that's no fun. The Fun for us
is at this segmentation and the fun,
frankly speaking is the
barriers that we come across.
No amount of Google search can help
us all that and that is what keeps us
frankly glowing. Even if it takes a lot
of capital, it takes a lot of investment,
a lot of time.
That's the mission of the company
and that's what we want to achieve.
Great.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
you had to summarize what was just
said there in 20 words or less,
what would it be?
Okay. Sasha, well,
bottom line
company that their mission
is not purely thing.
Okay.
And now help people who don't talk
bottom line counts to understand what you
just said.
Um, so some of you talk about a double
or triple bottom line and then you have
people who are looking at social returns
and environmental returns in addition
to purely financial returns.
Okay. So to rip, that's
terrific. So heretofore four,
we have talked as if
companies had one bottom line
and their net results were correctly
reflected in a profit and loss statement.
And what Sasha is suggesting is that a
firm like Selco a or a bank like seawall,
uh,
thinks about more than one bottom line.
And they want to say that some
net losses in the financial bottom line,
uh,
may be balanced and over compensated by
gains in environmental territory or in
social services.
So this is capitalized capitalism
hybridized with a nonprofit service sector
institutions and Selco and seawater are
neither of them institutions which would
have been designed if you thought
about just one bottom line,
right? The merit in them, uh,
has to be captured in social and
to some extent environmental terms.
Now,
um,
what the what, what's
the market's message, uh,
to village India about the availability
of light and electric current for
purposes like running a running
small machinery or heating water?
What's the market say?
Yes. This is a case where there's
exactly as economists say,
an equilibrium outcome.
What's somebody's got a hand
up over there are there we are,
I mean for the darkness area there's
simply insufficient demand to justify
expanding the infrastructure
of drastically. Okay.
Across much of rural India.
All right, so that's, go ahead.
Adam Smith distinguishes between total
demand and when he called effective
demand. Total demand is how many people
put up your hand, put up their hands.
If you say, would you
like electricity? Uh,
effective demand is people who would
do that and back it up with money
and effect. Effective
demand is very low. Now,
not only is it low,
but overcoming it with a grid structure
is inherently difficult because while
there are some customers capable of paying
market rate for grid electricity,
the vast majority of customers in many
of these regions are below that income
level and could not
afford any of the above.
In addition to that,
there poverty is reinforced by
the absence of energy supplies,
right?
If you don't have the energy supplies
to do small scale production or to
eliminate a market, uh, during, uh,
evening hours or any of a
hundred other such things,
the low level of commerce is
kept low by the absence of,
uh,
of efficient energy supplies.
So the justification for an enterprise
like this has everything to do with
finding a way around the
market equilibrium at zero,
uh, which prevails in
some of these places. No,
there was another feature
in the film clip. Uh,
what's the attitude toward customers?
How does their attitude compare with,
well, let's establish the,
the high end of the scale.
How does Gail do at providing a
choice of courses for you to take
ridiculously well,
right?
A third of Yale courses
have fewer than 10 students
think that,
oh,
imagine that you brought a cost accountant
in here to look at your college.
20% of my brothers and sisters on the
faculty, we'd be looking for a job.
And the enormous wealth of the
institution is what makes this possible.
And it's a wonderful thing.
Now,
if you were now,
now go,
go back to what's your least favorite
company that you deal with routinely?
Most of you have an unfavorite company.
I see a good nod right back
in the six row. Third seat in
my least favorite company
ever is Connecticut Limo.
Okay.
Connecticut Limo Wa there.
I ask,
they don't give customers what
they promise. They're always late.
They're too expensive and they're mean
me. Okay. Anybody else got an
over here?
Mcdonald's.
What's your grudge against them?
Uh, many, uh,
first how they market to children and uh,
how unhealthy their food is in general.
Okay.
Uh,
how many of you have eaten at Mcdonald's
sometime in the last two weeks?
That's a really interesting data.
We're at about 3%.
Okay.
I'll bet you are the lowest
Mcdonald's demographic in the country.
Um, okay. But your
objection to Mcdonald's,
is it, is it that they don't offer a
wide enough range of, of customizations?
Partly.
Okay. I mean, if I were
them, I'd say to you,
come on, what's the beef we offer
you? What is it? 2020 sandwiches.
Five breakfast.
Uh,
is it one flavor or more or two of
ice cream too? To have ice cream?
It's quite a lot. Your beef is
of another nature, isn't it?
That they,
that they popular as unhealthy food.
Okay. So you, uh,
and if you were king,
would you put them out
of business? Yeah. Okay.
Uh, I have a good friend and prominent
faculty colleague named Kelly Brownell.
Kelly Brownell visible to all of you.
Some of you round now is the
leading advocate of the fat tax.
He himself is a big guy actually,
but he wants to tach restaurant fat so
that there would be an excise tax on the
big Mac of three or four bucks because
it is just one huge blob of cholesterol.
Um, but we're off topic here. Uh,
the least favorite,
my least favorites are several airlines,
uh,
and providers of Internet service
and providers of a television signal
and it's because they're rigid.
Their business strategy strategy involves
a rigid interface with customers and
the Delta shuttle between
here and Washington, brutal,
just brutal the way they do it and that,
and there's a reason for that.
It's not just because they're bad
people or not even bad people.
It's because there are huge economies
in not listening to the details of what
people want.
Do want a ticket on the shuttle or do
you not want a ticket on the shuttle?
It will leave at age 70,
full stop end of conversation.
And it isn't even actually a conversation.
It is an interplay with a website
and the website is often Kludgy,
uninformative and so on.
But in a cost benefit ratio
from their point of view,
it works really well.
So when,
when you look at Selco the first,
my first impulse would be to say simplify,
don't customize.
Get one product that you can generate
at much lower costs and stay with it.
Okay.
Uh,
remember,
remember how in the dialogue in the film
clip and in the case he talks about one
size fits all,
doesn't work.
And what he means is that people who
can barely afford this equipment are
inclined to take it only if you match
it very well with their preferences.
Now
is that is somebody defense?
Selco please.
They're highly defendable.
I mean,
I guess this goes back to the bottom line
we talked about and where cell phones
cys not just a for profit bottom line.
They really want to help people in.
That comes up along the case where in
the end they talked that about what the
name of them manager Silka is that he
really wanted to help these people and
unless he tries to at least to
some extent customize as products,
you won't be able to help as
many people as you'd like.
Okay. That's good. And
hand the mic on here,
it's also sort of about
growing the market, right?
Because if you provide a customized
solution, just say, um, you know, uh, uh,
a street vendor and that vendor is able
to, you know, like this storefront,
make more money and maybe in the future
when he's adding another side to his
store for it to come back to you
and you know, by the full package.
Okay.
So there is a,
there's a sort of multiplier effect when
in the, on the commercial side of this,
you've customized it correctly. Now, um,
the major issue in the background
here is what's the size of this market
worldwide ballpark,
somewhere around a billion.
So they're a hell of a lot
of customers out there.
And
the,
and if that's so scalability
as it's called becomes,
uh,
a pressing question for a firm like Selco
and
scalability would mean that you could
drive your costs low enough and,
uh,
develop your distribution system strongly
enough that you can reach vastly more.
You know, there they are.
When the case is written,
they're still well under 10,000 households
and at well under 10,000 households.
This is an experiment,
a noble experiment,
but merely that it is a
demonstration project.
Now,
um,
a background fact about them,
which isn't in the case is this,
I had lunch today with
a Yale college alum, uh,
who worked last year for an Indian
company that manufacturers equipment like
this GWP and GWP assigned her the task
of finding a sales relationship with cell
cub.
So she spent a year working with
Selco trying to sell them a high,
high quality but completely
standardized system.
Okay.
That wa that was designed
to achieve scale economies.
And
her experience was entirely frustrating
because Selco ultimately,
ultimately wasn't interested
in achieving scale.
They were interested in serving the
immediate customer base in front of them.
Okay. What does that mean? I think it
means that Selco is a service company,
uh, and is destined to
remain a very small one.
Now,
in the case there's, in, in the B case,
there's some discussion about
they're a not for profit financing.
They may remember the amount
of financing they have
no, no reason. You should $462,000,
which isn't an is it a
monumental? Some, uh, but it's,
it's a pretty hefty sum if you're
talking about a few thousand customers
and the rhetoric in the bks is no,
no,
we're going to get to 300,000 customers
and the unit costs will be a dollar and
change per customer serve.
The subsidy will be that small.
Well, I actually don't think
they're going to get there.
I don't think it can be done
with this level of customization.
Okay. So now the task is each of
you as a management consultant. No.
And you're brought in by the
board of the funder for Selco.
Okay.
And you've got to figure
out how to take the,
take the baby out of the bath water,
get rid of the bath water and
come up with something scalable.
How would you go about that?
Anybody got a thought?
Where did we fire management or not?
Oh, over at uh, yes.
First I would try to get them to stop
being dependent on one geographic area.
It seems like they really concentrated
between Bangalore and I think it was, um,
Dubai.
Yes.
And like clearly there are a lot of poor
regions in India and once they get out
of those,
that specific region,
I'm pretty sure there'll be forced
to look at it a bit differently.
Okay. So let me, let me see
if I understood that. Uh,
do you want them to move
into higher income groups?
No. Okay. I want them to
go to another poor region.
Okay. You want them to go to another
poor neighborhood and do what?
And clearly by seeing that there are like,
since there are so many different cultures
within India and so many different
needs, if they continue this model
of customization, they will see,
they will ultimately fail and they need
to start moving into something else.
Okay. Um, I'm going to
pretend to be another person,
a person on the board lot.
We've already figured out these guys
are running straight into a dead end.
I'm impatient. You're all you're going
to do is demonstrate failure again.
Find me a better solution
now.
Anybody think,
think they've got one?
Yes,
it's far back.
Uh, yeah. I just figured out, um,
a couple of cell coast products,
a couple of their best products that
numerically meet the needs of the most
number of people. And then I would
expand by pushing those products.
And of course in the process you'd lose
out on customization and individual
solutions.
But if your goal is to
provide illumination to the
maximum number of people,
just kind of focus on
what you're good at it,
it's focused on a few product.
Sounds like a good idea. Now,
what about people who are,
you remember there's talk
in the case about a pyramid,
there's even a picture of a pyramid and
we're talking about serving people near
the bottom of the pyramid economically.
Is there a way that you might think
about serving people at the bottom of the
pyramid by all sort of serving people a,
a layer or two above them in the pyramid?
Yes.
If you can charge the people a little
bit higher up on the pyramid more
well the systems they can subsidize.
Yeah.
Okay. So if you can take off, take a,
you probably have to have the
product differentiated a little bit.
If you produce a higher
margin product, uh, which is,
uh,
very similar to your,
your straight product and build a
distribution channel in so that the same
distributors can cover the higher margin
product and also the low margin product
for the people at the bottom
of the pyramid and achieved
some scale economies so
that you begin to make
the pump run on its own.
MMM.
And there and in the, the video clip
we just watched, they talk about how,
uh, when they let distributors
do what they want it,
the distributors ended up drifting
into higher income straight up. Right.
And that's not very surprising because
the margins can be much higher right in
the bottom, the bottom channel, unless
you get the thing very standardized,
uh, the margins have to be negative
because people just can't afford her.
So high customization at the very bottom,
it looks like a highly problematic, uh,
strategy inspiring as it may be.
MMM.
Is there,
are there other lines of
production unrelated to
electricity that strikes you as
interestingly analogous to this?
For example,
let's say the nub of this
idea is distributed production
instead of centralized
grid production, we're
doing distributed, electric,
productive production of electricity.
Just as we have distributed
computing on all these laptops.
Are there other,
uh,
highly distributed strategies that
might be of service in bottom billion
countries?
Okay.
Okay. Um, talk, say more. Uh,
you could distribute mobile phones
instead of, you know, building a,
a land line. Okay. It,
has anybody thought of that yet?
I'm sure. Yeah. Well big time,
right? I mean, and the,
the story here is landlines
become completely saturate
the market and then cell
phones are a layer on top of that in
all the countries we'll be talking about
with the bottom billion, uh,
cell phones just over landlines,
right?
Yeah.
And are technologically superior to land
lines for all from almost every point
of view and a very low income settings.
So that's a,
that's a good suggestion. Any other
occurred? Anyone? Okay. Jennifer?
Water purification.
Okay. Water purification.
And the technology there is,
well how do you do it?
Well, instead of running pipes to
transport clean water to remote places,
you could just build their own
filters or dig their own wells.
Okay. You could build your own
filters, dig your own wells,
might or might not work depending on
the water table's depth and quality.
Um, but yes, it's a very good point,
right at the end of the semester
we'll see occasion, Bolivia,
Cochabamba Bolivia where um,
we try to fix a water supply system using
straight capitalist technique and get
into a lot of trouble. And we get into
a lot of trouble for it before the,
basically because the pricing model for
the capitalist to make money leads to
too high a price for people who
are right at the bottom of Bolivia.
Bolivia is pyramid,
which is not very different from India's
pyramid except it's got a lot less
growth in it. Thank you.
Anybody else got one?
Um, fighting malaria for example,
you could focus on like big projects,
you alter the landscape like draining
swamps versus just giving people like
mosquito nets in their own homes.
Okay. And the gates was
agree with you, right?
Uh,
and are throwing Belgians pattern.
And uh,
in general there was this whole family
of models for multiple bottom line
businesses and some natural
not so multiple bottom lines.
So straight out for profit businesses
were having decentralized production.
Sure.
As in shellcodes equipment
is a terrifically valuable,
uh, asset, no for Monday,
uh,
the main metric that is used in the
world for progress and what defines the
bottom billion as bottom
billion is GDP per capita.
And in my part of Monday's class,
which I'm about to record,
I'm going to pick APP.
I'm going to start with the proposition,
maximize GDP per capita,
and make our country better.
And Paul Cod, you're more or less
advocates that in the bottom Belgium.
And I'm,
I'm sympathetic to that view,
but I'll set up sub critical screens
to pass it through and explain those.
Uh, and you'll, you'll see that video
at the beginning of class on Monday.
And then after my little video,
there is a Ted talk by Paul Collier
explaining what he thinks his book has to
offer.